[Musik]
hier sollen die römer gepflanzt haben
der baum ist mindestens 2000 jahre alt
[Musik]
der film
erzählt die geschichte einer jungen
spanierinnen namens alma deren eltern
lange jahre einen olivenhain besessen
haben die dann aber unter dem druck der
wirtschaftlichen veränderungen auf seine
hühner master umgestellt haben was vor
allem wenn großvater der familie sehr
traurig macht und alba die zunehmend
sehr intensiv jetzt verhältnis hat sucht
nach dem grund dieser traurigkeit und zu
findet heraus dass es mit einem
konkreten um liefen baum zu tun hat
und die geschichte von el olivo ist
dagegen diejenigen dass alba mit zwei
freunden versucht diesen baum zurück
nach spanien zu bringen damit hat es
eine besondere bewandtnis die dann eben
auch ein bisschen zu spannung des films
beiträgt
juli wo ist eine spanische film von
einer regisseurs namens ist ja wohl ein
fast wichtiger noch als die regisseurin
esther drehbuchautor zu nehmen es
handelt sich um den briten paul laverty
rapper ti hat ein sehr gutes ohr für die
übersetzung von politischen
zusammenhänge sich zum beispiel diese
alba eine figur die tatsächlich glaube
ich für junge leute eine sehr gute
identifikationsfigur abgibt ein leicht
parkes mädchen mit einem starken
idealismus und eben diesen dieser
besonderen hartnäckigkeit die es eben
auch manchmal braucht wenn es darum geht
verhärtete politische umstände zu
überwinden
es ist ein film der sich in erster linie
an ein publikum richtet das
wahrscheinlich die anliegen teilt um die
es hier geht und das sind anliegen auf
die man sich glaube ich ja wirklich
vielfach einigen wird können nicht in
fremde landwirtschaft eine lebensform
die mit den wurzeln zu tun hat das sind
themen die alma aufbringt und die noch
verhandelt werden
scheiße an ich habe gedacht die
deutschen seien eine bande habgieriger
arschlöcher die hierher kommen haben
sich als rentner die hämorrhoiden
korrigieren zu lassen auf unsere kosten
menschen die sich für diese dinge
interessiert oder die eben auch so ein
bisschen decken werden mit diesem film
ihre
freude haben und in dieser form ist juli
wo finde ich ein fast ein
markenzeichen dessen dass heute das
politisch engagierte arthouse kino kann
und auf diese weise ist es auch durchaus
ein sehr sehenswerter film
es heißt
das ist doch unser warm